Hausa going rose manage periodic pack
today we're gonna play dance wall remix
because I have no good reason for what
I'm about to do but I apologize I mean
if you throw up look good let's do the
sky street oh my god it's working so
well oh yeah let's go collect all the
hearts oh oh no what you doing his son
that's right Oh party put it on whoa
party all night I'll go with the rainbow
Oh what I now they huh see these haters
can you games like this you have the
same bra size no that's not my problem
yeah I mean it doesn't get more manly
than this but to be honest here
yeah what is my family
ah can't wait to see the comments in
this video
oh wait oh oh it's still better than the
connect let's be honest here yeah it's
my jam
go away ah me neither
this is Jayden high school musical holy
[ __ ]
mocha fabulous it should take fabulous
pay incredible oh stop it
yeah superb [ __ ] yeah ah
think it it's a ke to be gay
it's alright it's okay it's okay to be
gay am i singing well thanks I like all
the diamonds
how about Teddy bass Oh shoosh shoosh
what was that what was that they wanted
me to be a perv
so okay look at my tits oh god I got
this right there I'm sorry oh yeah yeah
hit that [ __ ] oh come at me diamonds I
better close my window I don't know
never serious three stars that's better
oh nice pictures great alright let's try
a new thing
my body's dancing inside oh my god
this is my favorite song yes
so cute oh my neck my back it just
cracked if this is not gay then I don't
know what gay is but I love it
oh oh no way haters oh oh oh go back
away heaters go away he just can't stop
the families oh oh yeah awesome Wow
ice cream twerk twerk twerk fabulous
haters can't touch this that all you got
whoa number one all the truck [ __ ] em
that's the cleric cap yeah I'd go with
haters you can't stop me from dancing I
think if I won okay I promise I'll never
do that again
I'm so sorry but anyway if you enjoyed
watching please leave a like please
don't let me keep you later myself on
internet for nothing thank you but
that's all for now as always stay
awesome bro